[музика]
Привіт мене звати кучаренко Дарія ми
знаходимося в селищі печаніги
Харківської області я займаюся розробкою
проекту молодіжного простору для нашої
громади провадила таку ініціативу як
заходи для дітей віком 7ми та 12 років
на своєму подвір'ї це були майстер-класи
і настільні ігри там якісь Заходи які
діти самі мені запропонували Зараз я
шукаю приміщення яке було б відповідало
вимогам
безпеки і щоб можна було там проводити
час молодді мені здається що це було б
дуже корисно для нашої
громади я вважаю що покоління Перемоги -
це ми це така активна молодь як я нашу
молодь повинні підтримувати старше
покоління для того щоб кудись направляти
і допомагати своїми знаннями щоб наше
майбутнє було на високому
рівні